- [Eric] What's up guys?
I'm so freakin' excited for this video.
Hair get under control please
this is an important video.
Today I'm doing a collab
with the Emma Chamberlain.
Okay, if you don't know
who Emma Chamberlain is
(sneezes)
- [Emma] Oh my god, I like
sneezed and almost peed.
- [Eric] She basically
just blew up in a year.
And is completely crushing it on YouTube.
So yeah, I'm super
excited to work with her.
She's hilarious, everybody loves her,
she's a pretty big deal.
Do you want to record the video tomorrow?
- Record what video tomorrow?
- [Eric] With Emma Chamberlain.
- Yes!
- [Eric] I was so nervous.
I feel like, I don't know,
I want it to be a good video.
She's very funny and I feel like I'm
gonna just sit there and not have
anything to say.
Alright, you know what Eric?
You're (bleep) confident.
Manifest this (bleep)
I'm Eric mother(bleep) Tabach.
Also, I'm gonna be editing like Emma,
because you guys are here for Emma, so.
- [Emma] Hey.
- [Chris] Hey.
- [Emma] What's up vlog?
- [Chris] Stop with vlogging already.
- [Emma] I'm vlogging.
- [Chris] Before we do anything, I wanna
show you BuzzFeed.
Exclusive Emma Chamberlain
BuzzFeed review right now.
- [Emma] Opinion.
- [Chris] Opinion.
- [Emma] How honest should I be?
Should I be sensitive?
- [Chris] Fully honest.
- [Emma] Definitely Men in Black vibes.
Worried about it, might die here.
Ah, this is so cute.
This looks exactly like my cat at home.
Miss you Oliver.
(blows kisses)
(farting noises)
- [Eric] This is like, the most like
L.A. vibe.
- [Emma] Uh-huh.
- [Eric] Like the used--
- [Emma] Oh, wow.
- [Chris] The used part
of the BuzzFeed office.
Whoa.
- [Emma] Yeah this is, spectacular.
I'm not even gonna make a joke about it,
it's really great.
This might be the most
Instagram-able place
I've ever seen in my life.
Are you ready for this?
I might have to Instagram her.
- [Chris] Emma's Instagram is on fire.
She has like, one million
likes of every single picture.
She has three million followers,
this is the secret to Instagram.
This is how you do it.
- [Emma] Yes, do a hair flip,
do a little look back, another look back.
- [Chris] Do you always narrate while you
take the pictures?
- [Emma] I have to, or
else I feel uncomfortable.
- [Chris] Oh okay, gotcha gotcha.
- [Emma] Also if others are around,
there's like, I have like, one friend
in my life where like, I can take photos,
and not do like visibly uncomfort--
commentary about it because,
taking photos is not something that's
not awkward, it's awkward.
- [Chris] Alright, snack time.
You ready for snacks?
- [Emma] Yes.
(soft music)
- [Chris] Tasty's right over there.
Do you watch Tasty's videos?
- [Emma] Of course, funny story.
I used to watch those in class.
I was literally, like, watching, like
putting cheese inside of a chicken breast
instead of watching math lessons.
- [Chris] What's you
takeaways about BuzzFeed?
- [Emma] Good snacks, good
coffee, good almond milk.
Instagram situation, unmatched.
- [Chris] Okay, so Emma
is here in New York
because you're like a fashion-girl now.
- [Emma] Just give me all
of the clothing lines.
So apparently now I am a
respected fashion guru,
and if I'm not invited to
Fashion Week next year,
there's gonna be issues
and I will be suing.
- [Chris] Fashion is like,
not really that hard,
I feel like if you just
throw things on, like,
and you pull it off, anybody--
I honestly believe if you
have a good personality,
confidence is key.
- [Emma] The king is wrong.
Having a good personality,
being a good person,
that only gets you so far in life,
if you have a fire fit,
if you can do both,
you dominate the world.
- [Chris] I don't know.
Here's what I wanna do.
I wanna challenge you to
a thrift store challenge.
- [Emma] Down.
- [Chris] And prove to you
that anyone can thrift.
- [Emma] I'm down, I mean,
we'll see what happens here.
Um, I mean, I'm not gonna shut you down,
but I'm also worried,
concerned and good luck.
Rules of the game, me and you,
going head to head to try to pick
out the best, fancy
outfit we possibly can.
What do you win?
Absolutely nothing.
Not a thing, literally nothing.
- [Chris] Already, so, uh..
(Emma chuckles)
Let's go thrifting.
(car honks)
Alright, so we're at the thrift store,
this is Goodwill Curated.
- [Emma] Whatever.
- [Chris] I don't know what curated means,
but it's like,
a good thrift store.
- [Emma] Yeah.
- [Chris] How much time do we have?
- [Emma] I think we have 15 minutes.
- [Chris] 15 minutes?
- [Emma] 15, one-five.
Good luck.
Let's go.
- [Chris] Here's my game plan.
I'm just gonna pretend like I know
what the (bleep) I'm doing,
I don't, but I'm gonna talk like I do.
So, we're trying to find like a cool,
stylish, red carpet outfit.
Purple, imagine like, just bold.
What if I go super bold with this?
I feel like my game
plan is to go so crazy,
that people think it's style.
Oh my god, are these gold sneakers?
Don't these look like shorts that
just keep going?
Wow.
(laughter)
Have you ever seen anything like this?
(sniffles)
- [Emma] Um, so I have
to pick something out
for me, which is stressful because,
I can tell they don't have any gowns,
so we're gonna have to get creative.
Oh.
Imagine me in this.
That ain't it.
My nipple will pop through it,
but that's extra likes
for the Instagram, so.
This is 8th grade graduation dance.
I don't need to commentary on that.
You can just, do,
imagination with that one.
This looks like something, that like,
a mermaid would wear in a movie,
when it's like, they finally like,
get legs, and then they're like,
come on land and they're like,
(magical music)
There's a decent chance that he will
win because, I'm so sorry,
but putting on a suit is...
Easy.
♪ Prince Ali, Fabulous he, Ali Ababwa. ♪
- [Eric] That's a no.
I feel very uncomfortable.
Who's that teddy bear with the umbrella
that walks around, some
sort of like cartoon?
Do you know what I'm talking about?
- Paddington?
- [Eric] Paddington.
Pattington, I'm going
with a Paddington look.
It's like this.
Yes?
- Yeah.
- [Eric] Yes.
Now I just need pants, right?
All is need is pants.
Where are pants?
(upbeat music)
Mom, which pants?
- [Emma] He just called his mom.
Listen, listen to him.
Getting all the frickin' advice from her,
as if, as if this is--
No!
- [Eric's Mom] I would not
date you in this look, Eric.
- [Emma] Did he leave these pants here?
- [Eric] Hey no, do not touch my pants.
What, stop it.
These are gonna be amazing.
- [Emma] I might actually win.
- [Eric] Don't make me second
guess myself right now.
I'm already freaking out.
Really?
(Emma laughs)
I can't tell if you're being honest.
- [Emma] Those are so
awesome, I'm tearing up.
- [Eric] Stop it, I don't--
- [Emma] Is that even your size?
How do you know?
- [Eric] I don't, I actually don't.
(bleep)
- [Emma] Oh, I guess it's time.
- [Eric] Mine didn't vibrate yet.
- [Emma] Well, mine did.
- [Eric] Well, okay screw it.
You know what, I'm right.
So no one's gonna get in my head.
Okay, not Emma, not my mom,
you gotta believe in yourself, okay?
You gotta just, be you.
(upbeat music)
♪ You make, ♪
♪ Me feel. ♪
♪ Love, ♪
♪ love. ♪
- [Eric] What are you doing?
- [Emma] It's not that bad.
Why is it not that bad?
I'm so mad.
But I mean, I still look better.
- [Eric] What did I say though.
If you're bold, if you're bold
you commit to crazy looks.
(soft music)
- [Emma] Sorry, I can't
hear what he's saying
cause I don't care because
I'm about to go ride horses.
(horses nay)
- [Loud Speaker] Attention
Goodwill shoppers,
uh, we're having a competition
going on in our store,
for Buzzfeed video.
So, anybody in the store
who has any insight
on fashion and style, we
would love to hear from you,
just head to the back of the store.
- I honestly, like this look.
(Eric yells)
- [Eric] Yes, hug it out.
- I'm gonna give it to
Emma, for creativity.
- I like your outfit too.
- (Eric yells)
- [Emma] I hate, I hate the --
- [Eric] It is two-one,
I've won, and that's that.
- [Emma] That's the tea, he won.
Honestly, well deserved.
That outfit's better, but I mean,
what's in my heart is--
- [Eric] You think the outfit's better?
- [Emma] Yeah.
- [Eric] So, for a first time shopper,
and thrift-time shopper--
- [Emma] You did pretty good.
- [Eric] I did good?
- [Emma] You actually, genuinely did it.
- [Eric] And you know why?
Because I watch her thrift store videos.
- [Emma] Oh my god, that's
actually really great.
Guys, go check it out.
- [Eric] Go check out the thrift videos.
- [Emma] And if you wanna
be as talented as him,
and as talented as me.
Alright, have a good one.
- [Eric] Have a, life.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Unsolve is on a new channel.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.